obviously the kyle rittenhouse trial has
been this week and it's been just a
perfect example um of the split in this
country that people watch the exact same
thing and just see it in completely
completely different ways but so there
are two videos i want to throw to here
first off half of the internet half of
twitter which maybe i should be spending
less time on uh have
no doubt about that
uh yes half of twitter was going crazy
because the judge his phone rang during
the trial and you're not gonna believe
what his ringtone was take a listen
i i don't think that's
necessarily what i'm supposed to do
but i think the court has to make some
findings as it relates to
the bad faith on the part of the
prosecution
and if the court makes a finding that uh
the actions that i had talked about
[Music]
were done in bad faith
that i think both
elements
if you didn't quite catch that uh the
judge's ringtone was god bless the usa
which i'm not even gonna bother showing
you the amount of blue check twitter
people who are saying that he's now a
white supremacist this is the call of
magga and trump i mean just absolute
insanity lauren i know you've been
paying a lot of attention to the trial
so any direction you want to go here
well so first off this is not the only
time that the judge has had his phone
ring with that ringtone it happened
several times today uh just the uh the
jury has been dismissed for for the
weekend but there's still a meeting
between the defense prosecutor and the
judge this has happened several times
just today uh this judge is more popular
than me i tell you because his phone is
just ringing off the hook non-stop
but it's very strange for the left to
you know oftentimes it's the right that
is
alleging that the left is not patriotic
you don't actually love your country and
we hear the left go like no no that's
not true just patriotism is not just for
the right and i agree that it should not
be but then here uh we see very clearly
that when confronted with a song that is
obviously patriotic god bless the usa
they are so quick to uh connect that to
white supremacy donald trump mega
political biases like wait a second i
thought you guys were arguing that this
type of thing was for everybody now all
of a sudden because it suits you and
you're trying to paint the judge's bias
you're saying it's this uh you know i
guess dog whistle toward the far right
which is ridiculous he's also been
called a a racist because he referred to
like asian delivery that the the jury
had ordered as an asian person um that's
i don't understand how that is racist in
any way shape or form but i think they
know the trial is not going the way that
they want so they are just looking at
anything they can pick apart to say this
was biased uh re-trial et cetera et
cetera lauren you're obviously a
self-hating asian because you're not
offended enough right stu what do you
make of the trial
just generally speaking what do you
think is happening here at this point
well first of all i do want judges in
our uh
justice system that know how to put
their phone on silent yeah and that is a
real problem uh we do need to solve that
one it seems like the left though just
wants him to have the soviet national
anthem instead and then they would be
fine with it you know i don't mind my
judges liking america i think it's
actually kind of a a good thing um
and and we have a justice system that is
supposed to push back against twitter
and you're seeing in the written
house saga that this is what happens
when you turn that justice system over
to people who are on social networks
this is a social network fueled fi uh
trial it should not even be a trial at
all we have video of every moment of
this and anyone who watches it can
clearly see he's in a position of
self-defense a couple really important
parts of of what you see on video where
where uh someone comes up to attack kyle
rittenhouse he brings his gun up and
points it at them they back off and he
does not fire that is crucial to what is
in his mind at this time and we're all
going to i think agree that he should be
he should not be convicted of of these
really harsh charges um however that's
not really enough you know it's not
enough for him to just get an acquittal
they've ruined his life for a year
and while i think you can sincerely look
because i have a i have a 10 year old
son and in seven years i am not going to
advise him to take guns to riot scenes
and try to patrol them i don't think it
was a good decision and you can
criticize that decision but this is a
court of law uh we can all talk on
twitter we can talk on on on on the
internet about what we think the right
choice was uh as far as his travel plans
for that particular uh evening um but
when it comes down to the law this is
supposed to be open and shut and in this
case it should have even been open there
is no there's no reason with the amount
of video that we have of this case that
it should have ever been able to get to
this point i i think what's happening
here is what we've seen so often lately
and it's it's the two courts in which
we're prosecuted one is the court of law
and the other one is the court of public
opinion and the court of public opinion
is very quick to rush to judgment and
that's what we're seeing in kyle
rittenhouse's case honestly you guys i
think if you were to pull the majority
of americans who are like kind of on the
surface following this case i don't
think they realize that the victim
doesn't i will call them victims um the
two men that were shot by written house
three if you include the survivor we're
all white i really don't think people
realize that honestly um if i'm being
completely honest it wasn't until
recently that i did i just assumed i
mean he was at a black lives matter
protest
um and the way the left has reacted to
this and and the divide that we've seen
in regards to him and calling him a
white supremacist i just figured the
people that were killed and the one that
was shot were black
and i still think there's a lot of
people that believe that to this day so
the fact that that the victims were all
white is kind of being glossed over by
the left i think that's really telling
as far as how they want uh to paint the
picture of this trial and what's going
on in the court it's a great point i
mean the guy shot three white people
without getting into the specifics so
it's like he's not doing white supremacy
that great